hello everyone
i'm avoc i was invited by gq to talk
about
10 things that are essential to my life
[Music]
you know since all this happened i kind
of reconnected
to things that were really essential for
me i've been spending way more time at
home here
and it was very important because
i just became a dad my son has just
bored in january
i could now spend way more time with him
and get really connected
with my family and my wife it gives more
sense to my life
[Music]
so the last years i've been spending
most of my time in hotels and airplanes
around the world
and now basically i spend most of my
time here at home
so the second thing that's very very
essential for me
is my home you know to be here um this
is
the spot and the third thing that's
very important to me i'm gonna show you
guys right now so come over
[Music]
every time i get inspired i love to come
here to my piano
and search um for which notes are
connecting to my feelings
and i really do love to start every song
with the melody when i get the melody
done
um the process to create my song is
basically to
get everything that i made here and
bring to the fourth element
which is essential to me which is my lab
let me show you guys come over
here's the lamp actually
it's inside here my secret door
welcome
[Music]
so here is my lab here's a setup where i
produce all my songs
but also where i do my streaming twice a
week
with the gaming world you can see
different kind of setups here there's a
camera over there
there's my speakers this is my spaceship
basically
one of the most important elements that
i have in my life nowadays is a game
called free fire
which is actually the most downloading
game in the world
and i actually became uh one of the most
important characters inside you can see
it over there
i see them had the mustache but the two
is the same
when they ask me like which kind of
ability
inside the game would you like to have
and i thought about you know what if i
could choose any kind of superpower
i would choose to heal people and that's
actually the ability that i have inside
the game
all my royalties that i was going to
receive from my character
i'm actually donating through my
institute worldwide
i have already a project in africa which
we have more than 20
000 kids i have also here in brazil i
know that i won't change the world
but i can change their world
you know sometimes i just spend the
whole night here in the studio but i'm
never spending
alone because i have someone that's
always with me
we are inseparable
it's my partner in crime who spent the
whole night with me
apollo which is my dog
i always wanted to bring light to people
this is one of my missions here in life
we find a way out using laser i've been
using this
in all my concerts also i used in a huge
livestream that we did here in brazil
which we had more than 65
million streams at night and i also just
used and the finals of my championship
that i just did for free fire
you know so laser is a very essential
thing to my life
it's a way we find out to synthesize the
feeling that i had
to bring light to people
i love to use bracelets and i love to
use
rings but i don't use a traditional
wedding ring
instead of that i did a tattoo with the
initial
of my wife's name her name is ramana
[Music]
what's actually very important it's my
hair bubble
and uh you may ask him why i'll show you
why
that's why
and all of this wouldn't be possible
without people that surrounds me which
includes my family
and my team you know every time i ask
them
for the impossible they ask me five
minutes
so the tenth element that is essential
to me
it's actually not here it's out there
it's the sun and i love to see the sun
rising and i have the privilege to have
this
at my home here it represents something
very special to me
because even though you're having a bad
day
the sun will always rise tomorrow to
give you a new opportunity
[Music]